Ouija boards you do not open up portals
for anything to come through when you
can't control what's coming through a
lot of people with abilities have weak
borders and boundaries and so they're
all they're often overwhelmed by
mischievous entities that are sort of
messing with weak Minds is the way I
would put it so the reason the other
side comes through to children so often
is because they have weak borders and
boundaries and they're usually pretty
gentle so the other side's really drawn
to children but also people who do have
mental health issues or somebody who has
kind of suicidal at energy if they have
that tone to them sort of more of a low
frequency energy they're going to draw
in low frequency energy from the other
side so you sort of draw in what you put
out